[Music]
let's talk about the lakers for a second
they've uh they've had a difficult
season they have to
yeah
yes we do i'm contractually obliged
you were uh you know part owner of the
lakers and then you get out the last
time they went they beat the celtics in
10 and then you get out just as
everything starts to fall apart you are
a genius
how did you know this was gonna happen
how did you know you knew something it's
magic
um
you know you can can i can i go with you
to vegas please
i just want to go with you to vegas and
hang out you know it's just it's blowing
my mind that
a team with this much talent incredible
amount of talent yes you know when you
think about hall of famer kobe bryant
steve nash would probably be a hall of
famer dwight howard has a chance to do
that as well and you add gasal in there
this team is better than the eighth
place team in the west
and we've been up and down all season
long
and
i don't know we only have i think 13 or
14 games left right if they don't put it
together they're going to go out in the
first round and it's a shame because
again the talent is there i don't know
we we've had a problem with coach
d'antoni the system what the guys are
playing and then the guys themselves so
they're going to have to correct it but
the
the exciting thing for the lakers is
this
they can beat anybody they have the
talent to do that
will they get hot right before the
playoffs right and carry that over into
the play it's amazing you again all that
talent and it's just there's this thing
that's very hard to define where between
the coach the team and the team with
each other it doesn't matter they can
all be hall of famers it just has to gel
or it's not going to work you made a
good point if it if they do not come
together as a team
the talent doesn't matter right and and
so
they the thunder the spurs even the
clippers their their team their team the
lakers have not jailed as a unit yet